A great idea doesn't always guarantee great
movie.
Over the years there have been dozens of projects
floating around Hollywood that have gotten
audiences excited but for one reason or another
never made it to the big screen.
Here are Screen Rant’s Greatest Movies That
Were Never Made.
Return of the Jedi
Sure, fans got an end to the original trilogy
from director Richard Marquand but after Empire
Strikes Back, George Lucas approached several
filmmakers about the possibility of directing
the film.
You have to give Lucas credit for thinking
outside the box by considering names like
David Lynch and David Cronenberg.
Their edgy, experimental styles didn’t really
suit the established franchise, but the idea
of the minds behind The Fly or Twin Peaks
directing a Star Wars film is so out there,
that fans still can't resist imagining the
possibilities.
Napoleon
Perhaps the most famous unrealized project
of director Stanley Kubrick has to be "Napoleon."
Utterly obsessed with the military leader,
Kubrick had done so many years of research
into the French leader that he wound up with
a filing cabinet filled with index cards,
each detailing where Napoleon was, and why,
on any given day of his documented life.
But when 1970's Waterloo turned out to be
a flop, the studio got nervous.
Even though the research was used for his
film Barry Lyndon, Kubrick's epic biopic would
have been something special.
Gladiator 2
In 2008 it was revealed that Russell Crowe
had approached musician/writer Nick Cave to
pen a sequel to the Oscar winning period drama
Gladiator.
Since Maximus dies at the end of the first
film (spoiler), Cave wrote a script that begins
with Maximus in purgatory before being sent
back to earth by the gods to fight a new Christ
figure gaining popularity.
Cave wanted it to be called ‘Christ Killer’
and planned a climax with Maximus fighting
in famous battles through the ages up to present
day.
By all accounts it was an incredible script,
but one that could never be made by a major
studio.
Double V Vega
By now it’s common knowledge that the characters
of Vincent Vega in Pulp Fiction and Vic Vega
(aka Mr. Blonde) in Reservoir Dogs are brothers
in the Tarantino Cinematic Universe.
Since both characters died in their respective
films, Tarantino had kicked around ideas for
a prequel called Double V Vega that would
feature Vic visiting Vincent in Amsterdam.
There were even talks of a sequel where John
Travolta and Michael Madsen would play the
older brothers of Vincent and Vic out for
revenge, but with Tarantino claiming he’s
nearing the end of his directing career, and
the actors not getting any younger, it’s
highly doubtful that one will be the Vega
Brothers movie.
A Confederacy of Dunces
Over the years, the adaptation of this Pulitzer
Prize winning novel has had massive stars
attached, including John Belushi, John Candy,
Chris Farley, Will Ferrell and Zach Galifinakis.
There's no question it's a hit in the making,
but progress has been stalled by everything
from deaths to natural disasters like Hurricane
Katrina.
In 2013, director Steven Soderberg claimed
the project was cursed, making it hard to
believe it will be picked up any time soon.
Bioshock
In 2008, Gore Verbinski, hot off hits like
The Ring and Pirates of the Caribbean, signed
on to direct an adaptation of the surprise
hit video game BioShock.
Verbinski fought to make the story of a ruined
underwater utopia R rated, with a budget upwards
of $200 million.
When the R-rated Watchmen underperformed at
the box office, the studio saw it as proof
that the idea wouldn't work, and pulled the
plug on BioShock.
Some of the film’s concept art has since
been released online confirming that this
would have stayed true to the game’s popular
aesthetic while also representing Verbinsksi’s
unique vision.
Forty Lashes Less One
The only film Tarantino ever adapted from
someone else’s story is 1997’s Jackie
Brown, based on Elmore Leonard’s novel Rum
Punch.
Tarantino has mentioned several other Leonard
books he owns the rights to and would be interested
in adapting, with none more promising than
Forty Lashes Less One: the story of two condemned
men given the chance to earn their freedom
by hunting down the five most dangerous criminals
in America.
Tarantino had even begun writing the screenplay
at one point, but considering it’s another
western that deals with race and bounty hunters,
we probably won’t see Tarantino bring this
one to the big screen any time soon.
Halo
With names like Peter Jackson and Guillermo
del Toro attached, plus an incredible short
film by the then unknown director Neill Blomkamp,
it seems crazy that fans never got the Halo
film they were promised.
With a script by Alex Garland, who went on
to write Dredd and direct Ex Machina, the
film entered pre-production in 2004 before
getting completely bogged down by development
issues and studio politics.
All the initial players have moved on to various
projects, but the video game franchise is
still going strong, begging the question:
when is this going to happen?
Those are just some of the movies that could
have turned into Hollywood hits if they'd
actually been made, or tarnished the originals,
if they were a disappointment to fans.
Which movies do YOU wish had been made?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.